[Music]
okay science and good and evil good and
bad right and wrong
murder all these things human moral
values well I wrote a book about this
the moral arc I do I am a what's called
a moral realist I think there are real
moral values out there to be discovered
now not out there in the cosmos for
astronomers discover I'm talking about
in human nature in human social nature
and I'll just give you a super simple
example that I can't believe anybody
would disagree with this and it begins
with Abraham Lincoln's defense of why
slavery is wrong and he said simply if
slavery is not wrong nothing is wrong
and I would agree and go further with a
more recent example if the Holocaust is
not wrong nothing is wrong
now moral relativists or moral
philosophers who are not moral realists
they don't want to be called relevance
there's other positions but let's just
leave it at there's other positions that
moral realism are you seriously gonna
argue that there's some condition in
which the Holocaust was okay that it was
acceptable no mind you I'm talking about
all of us in this category here talking
about this are not thinking that God is
the answer that there's some outside
deity telling us what's right and wrong
most of us that that are in science or
philosophy already reject that going all
the way back to Plato who debunked that
idea in the first place which is to say
that if you know if murder is really
wrong or the Holocaust is really wrong
or slavery is really wrong why do we
need God to tell us that I mean if if if
those moral principles are out there and
God is just telling us what it is then
why why do we need the middleman just
tell us the reasons why it's wrong and
okay and if it's just because God said
it what if he he didn't say murder was
wrong would that make it right no no it
would still be wrong so either way you
don't need God so here we are in our
bubble of just us trying to figure out
what's right and wrong I argue in the
moral arc that in fact we are already
understanding what is right in
through the study of human nature and
human culture in human history by saying
there are certain things that are really
better than other things in the same way
that Kepler discovered planetary or
planetary orbits are elliptical and not
circular given that he was doing his
calculations correctly and given that
planetary orbits really are elliptical
and not circular he could hardly have
discovered anything else we would
eventually discover that democracies are
better than theocracies or dictatorships
just in terms of what the people want
based on their survival and flourishing
of sentient beings and that's my moral
foundation the survival and flourishing
of sentient beings we all want to
survive and flourish it's in our nature
it's what evolution designed us to
desire that is our moral foundation our
nature and that is who we are and what
we want ok building from there
ok so certain economic systems are
really better toward that than others
and you will discover that if you are a
rational being trying to figure out
what's the best way to structure things
now it's true that we can't solve every
moral issue by just running an
experiment but if you think about it
every nation with a different
constitution is an experiment every
state in the United States 50 different
states have 50 50 different
constitutions they have 50 different
laws about gun control or abortion or
well not quite that but they have
different variations on on how its it's
allowed or but just take anything you
know that so these are 50 different
experiments every Supreme Court justice
decision is an experiment ok let's see
what happens now that they decided this
let's measure the consequences of this
you know the the 19th amendment of
abolishing alcohol okay this was an
experiment a failed experiment so if the
if your goal is to reduce the amount of
drinking that didn't work so 21st
amendment abolished is the 19th
amendment those are all experiments so
this is what I'm talking about that is
this idea that David Hume put forth that
you can't derive a naught from it is
this is a red herring this is a
misdirection to that I say mr. Hume tear
down this wall
of course we can breach that wall of
course we can discover certain things
about what we ought to do based on the
nature of reality now here I'm not
talking about like because ants have
slavery or chimpanzees have war that we
should have slavery in war no I mean
what is the real nature of war and and
how should we reduce it understanding it
through the scientific study of war is a
way to get to attenuating it that's all
I mean and the reason we want to
attenuate is because it's bad for
sentient beings it reduces the amount of
survival and flourishing so that's
that's my argument for more real moral
realism
[Music]